[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
your host Mike McCarty here with Jake
Decker what's up how's it going good you
are in Australia but we figured we'd
still get you on a phone call so we
could talk about the last episode we put
up and kind of people's thoughts in the
comments whatnot yeah this is a good
episode which I actually had almost
nothing to do with I was out and Joey
kinda took over and was able to help you
with the edits right yeah I did both I
did the edits myself and then Joe we did
like tweaking once we got back and
everything so I was a huge help and
appreciate hard work from the gamespot
team as always this is one of our off
week episodes so we want to do some Q&A
and address a few comments on the
Nintendo I've missed you which was
episode 14
you mentioned Jake most many people are
pointing out that Bethesda never
supported Wii U so I think my phrasing
at the point was Bethesda Ubisoft an EA
and all in 2013 announced they weren't
supporting that Wii U as much
yeah so but as the like never really
brought games to the Wii U per se but
that was the year they've kind of flat
outside I think Pete Hines their head of
PR said yeah it's just a hardware thing
we can't develop for something when
there's such a huge gap between that and
you know a PlayStation 4 Xbox one and
whatnot so yeah that's good people
pointed that out but yeah so it's good
to see that kind of reversed as far as
third-party support goes obviously you
have Martin Plus Rabbids was a great
partnership between Ubisoft and Nintendo
you have mercury steam did the Metroid
Samus Returns which we also mentioned
and of course Bethesda is bringing doom
and Skyrim to the switch before the end
of the year I believe Skyrim is in
November I don't think doom has a
release a yet and then Wolfenstein 2
next year and while I'm sure none of
those will be as graphically
good-looking as ps4 Xbox one and
especially PC titles I'm really glad
that we'll be able to just you know like
play Doom on a long flight or play
Skyrim for like a bite-sized half hour
on the way to work on the bus I don't
know Jake have you been enjoying your
time with a switch I love it like I like
you mentioned in the video I think it is
my favorite way to play games I have a
PC I love my PC and there's definitely a
place for getting those highly graphical
games it's that that is amazing but
there's something just so unbeatable
about bringing
a little thing with me wherever I go and
the game still look great like even
though they're not it's not a powerhouse
but like you look at a game like Mario
Plus rabbits game looks gorgeous thanks
to art art style and same with Mario
Kart 8 like that game is that game looks
fantastic I'm super excited for anything
that gets announced for that especially
something like Skyrim or doom and to be
honest I have a feeling if these do well
I wouldn't be surprised if Bethesda like
tried to get fallout 4 on that - that
would be super cool yeah that'd be
awesome I have to imagine they would
they would might try that do you think
it's too late for them to try to bring
Elder Scrolls online like does that game
have enough support to even justify
bringing it to dance I down there
doesn't seem like the demographic I
guess cool but as always we have
questions from our YouTube comments and
as always the best part of our show we
love doing these off week episodes so
always be sure to comment critique our
episodes give us some feedback whether
it's positive or negative and we are
always open to that and I'll get to the
first question right now by today's big
on YouTube apologies if I butchered your
username today Vic said it's getting
good games but after trying it out for
several days he he or she loaned it from
a co-worker I must say it feels like
playing with a cheap plastic toy used to
get for free when purchasing wallström
gel for clothes it feels like it's going
to break any time it has cheap plastic
controllers buttons and analog controls
and it of course due to being Nintendo
it's very overpriced especially the
extra components or charging stations
and then they said I might get switched
when it's heavily heavily discounted
until then no Nintendo games for me so
unlike a couple things in here that kind
of stain I think the first thing that
really stands out is I don't think it
feels that cheap maybe it's because I
played the Wii U and that game yeah I
felt like a toy that this actually feels
like it feels like a really sleek piece
of technology like it's it's got a good
it's got a nice weight to it it feels
well-designed sturdy I think one thing I
will say is that the as cool as the joy
cons are they definitely aren't the
ideal weight to play like I'd much
prefer playing on a control which as he
said later is kind of overpriced but to
be honest like I kind of disagree with
that first thing he said however
overpriced that is
something I can agree with especially
with like all these peripherals
yeah like thinking ahead I don't think I
have to imagine doom or Wolfenstein
shooters that kind of require a lot of
coordination between both thumbs will
feel great on the in the tablet form for
the switch the portable form I'd
probably rather play those on a pro
controller at that point I'd probably
just rather play them on my ps4 but I
hope to be proven wrong but yeah I mean
I think it feels great too you said like
you said it has a nice weight to it for
a portable device it feels awesome it's
just like a tablet with you know
Nintendo looking controllers on either
side and they're not the best feeling
all the time but they get the job done
and like I think that's my preferred way
to play like Mario Plus rabbits for sure
Zelda for sure like the games are the
first party games that are coming to it
well I mean first and third party that's
in Mario Plus rabbits but that's like my
preferred way to play them because it
just feels so good and like you said
compared to the Wii U it's a vast
improvement yeah I mean even when you
look at all of like the 3ds is like I
think 3d ices are very built to be very
sturdy right because a lot of children
are gonna have them but they still kind
of look like toys and the switch doesn't
look like a toy necessarily to me it
looks like a really cool piece of
technology that that feels pretty well
designed like I'm sure there are little
things you can nitpick like the stand on
the back is pretty flimsy but still like
I'm pretty impressed and happy with the
design and how it feels in my hand cool
so thank you very much today's vague
again I'm apologized from pushing your
username that was on YouTube and that's
the primary place we go for comments
although in the coming weeks we want to
definitely focus a lot on going through
comments on our GameSpot pages so we'll
be like housing our reboot episodes and
like kind of written articles at the
that will have text below the actual
video and then so if you're a regular
YouTube user will still be going through
those comments but we'd also love you to
come over and check out the videos on
GameSpot because we also want to show
that crowd some love as well Jake do you
want to do the next and last question
that we found yes so this is from red
8th and he says I think we should slow
our horses there for a second there's
still a lot of things that aren't great
about the switch and we are only in the
first year everyone was praising the Wii
U in the beginning the switch UI and
online
of us are still pretty lacking if not to
say awful so let's wait and see if
Nintendo is actually listening some of
their ideas like the whole headset
debacle makes me think that they didn't
really get it fully that they still
don't get it fully coupled out to me but
yeah so the right when we first got
switches in the office the voice chat
was huge especially when I'm when Kali
plaguey of our editor she was reviewing
splatoon too she's kind of our shooter
she plays a lot of shooters so she was
playing splatoon too and loved the game
but it was was just so annoyed like a
lot of people that she had to go through
her phone and then at that time I
believe if your phone screen turned off
that would mess the chat up I think
they've since fixed that but still it's
so cumbersome I mean like you could use
discord but for a you know for a 2017
console to come out and not have voice
chat it's so weird because they're doing
so many other things well that this
seems like a huge oversight especially
with games like splatoon - and I'm
trying to think of like what other game
would try to use that as much like
that's the one kind of silver lining
it's not many games are on the switch
where I would want voice chat all that
much maybe Mario Cart if I was just like
talking friendly to people but like I I
can't imagine them going much longer
without figuring out solution for that
yeah they have to I mean especially if
they want it if they definitely want to
cater to those third parties because I
mean like although doom is and do my
play more for single plane I think a lot
of people mostly play that for
single-player I mean if the switch does
as well as people think it will will I'm
sure Call of Duty is something that's
going to be there and you're gonna need
voice chat for Call of Duty and I mean
obviously we don't know if Call of Duty
is gonna come to switch but I imagine
there's gonna be games like that that
you're definitely gonna want vice Chat
for it and it is an issue with splatoon
but as you're saying like Mario Kart I
don't really need voice chat for like I
don't know like more a lot of C's kind
of a you know like you're not gonna need
it for that yeah and like typically on
my switch I feel like I won't be playing
too many multiplayer games I I prefer
single-player games especially when I'm
on the go it just makes more sense but
yeah I mean I think voice chat is
something that
they should be sorted out sooner rather
than later yeah and one of the call a
couple other things so the online
services being pretty lacking like if
far the chat goes yeah and but I don't I
mean the Virtual Console I would love
for that to come fully over the switch
the eShop stuff is there now and I've
downloaded a few things through there
but having Virtual Console on there to
be able to play like this huge abundance
of more games like I feel like they
should have figured that out before they
released the console considering how you
know legendary Nintendo's Game portfolio
has been over the past couple decades
yeah I have no idea where that's not
available yet like I I hope it's soon
like it needs to be really soon yeah so
that is what the question those are the
questions we picked red eight thank you
for your youtube comment and again
everybody who is regularly watching
reboot or newcomers who might be kind of
getting into the series for the first
time these are off week episode we
always go through the youtube comments
our site comments for sure in the future
and also just tweet at us in general and
we would love to feature on the show
Jake before we go I wanted to ask you
one final question since again reboots
mostly my opinion so I like to give you
the chance to speak your mind do you
think you agree with me that in 2017
seems to be like Nintendo's year yes I
do
i I don't think Nintendo necessarily
left and I know a lot of people in the
comments said this like Nintendo has
been there this whole time but I think
they were definitely lacking in
direction I mean because I played a lot
of Wii U mostly because of Mario Kart
and Super Smash Bros which I've played
probably 600 hours of Super Smash Bros 4
Wii U and I love that game but I mean I
think what the biggest issue with it was
is that like everyone loves that game
but no one knew what a Wii U was like I
was like telling friends about it like
hey do you wanna play the news for
smashers like always it on Wii and I'm
like no it's on Wii U and like what's
that and it's like oh it's like a it's
like a follow-up like that can I use my
wiimotes and I was like yeah I guess you
can I don't know it was just like it was
very weird time for Nintendo like I
think they definitely had some excellent
games
but they just I feel like they just
missed out on a lot they they they
didn't really think a lot of things
through a lot of strategies through and
I think it hurt them and I think with
the switch they're definitely trying to
turn that around and one thing that you
mentioned in reboot was that they are
listening to their fans a lot more which
i think is super important I mean like
the Wii you went through the entire
lifecycle and we got a we got two Zelda
remakes and we got one Zelda game which
was at the very end which also launched
with the switch never got a Metroid
never got a Fire Emblem game on that
console it was just like a lot missing
and I was super bummed but at the same
time I definitely had fun with it but
yeah overall I agree with you however I
don't think they were necessarily gone I
think they were just hard to find and
they kind of did that to themselves yeah
all in all you know like a lot of us
around the officer saying like switch is
awesome we like it a lot there
definitely still some problems with it
but I mean they're they're on pace to be
my like kind of of the big three and
like I'm not in console wars obviously
like that stuff I like I like
competition fueling a Nintendo Xbox one
and ps4 like the competition pushing
them to do cool stuff but I definitely
think Nintendo has given me my most
memorable experiences this year you know
outside of like on my PC that's always
gonna be my favorite platform but as a
console goes it's so nice to have an int
endoplasm in general I think we have
nothing to be overly negative about you
know like the voice chats a problem for
sure I would love to see Virtual Console
sorted out and ready to get more play
time but yeah all in all I think
Nintendo is definitely kind of the
the one who's taking the biggest steps
in 2017 and I have nothing but uh but
expectations good expectations for Super
Mario Odyssey and you know hopefully
Skyrim is decent on the switch so I can
just play that on my commutes and
hopefully doom and castle not
Castlevania that would be awesome though
Wolfenstein yeah I mean there's so many
games look forward to on it too right
now I was listing a few on Twitter but
there's fire inland warriors there's a
full there's a full-fledged Fire Emblem
game but that won't come out for a while
Metroid Prime for obviously there's a
new there's gonna be like a fully
fledged Pokemon game there's a Xenoblade
Chronicles to like there's so much to
look forward to on this thing oh yeah I
can't wait I have nothing but high hopes
for the future
awesome well Jake thank you for phoning
in from Australia thank you as always we
will be back next week with a full-on
reboot episode where we're kind of
bouncing around a few different ideas so
we don't want to tease anything too much
yet but as always in the meantime hit us
up on Twitter at mo Hardy or Jakob deck
with two K's we usually respond to
pretty much everyone and we always
welcome criticisms or you know positive
or negative feedback so in the meantime
it is up there or on youtube or on
GameSpot calm and we will see you next
week thank you
[Music]
you